how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
[Music]
coming up on quick take
[Music]
i don't think you can overstate the
online communities or social medias
influence on financial markets let's
just suck it on up and take 50 000
here's a stock that can change your life
i see a stock going up and i buy it and
i just watch it until it stops going up
and then i sell it i have gained over 3
million dollars i want some free money
the revolutionaries on reddit are
spanking wall street's ass the more
these stocks go up the more the big guys
are getting creamed and losing billions
of dollars this isn't a wealthy person's
game anymore anyone can play it i took
up a little bit of a new hobby and i am
interested in day trading from brokerage
apps to discord channels and subreddits
to tick-tock influencers one of the last
holdouts in the world of disruption
finance is next in line
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
the pandemic has affected everyone in
different ways
i'm scarlet foo this is bloomberg quick
take a growing number of tennis players
and officials are asking where in the
world is pengshui the chinese tennis
star has not been seen publicly since
detailing a turbulent decade-long
relationship with a retired communist
party official she took to social media
this month accusing former vice premier
jung ali of coercing her into sex three
years ago peng's post was deleted around
30 minutes after it was published and
she has not been seen or heard from
since
so why is this significant and what
happens now i want to bring in chris
fenton he's a former hollywood film
producer and author of feeding the
dragon inside the trillion dollar
dilemma facing hollywood the nba and
american business chris it is always
good to speak with you welcome back to
quick take um clearly this story is
raising a lot of concerns around the
world you've got tennis stars like naomi
osaka tweeting about it
saying things like i'm not sure how many
people are aware of this but i do want
to point out that
this superstar tennis player from china
is perhaps
in danger censorship is never okay at
any cost she writes i hope feng shui and
her family are safe and okay i'm in
shock of the current situation i'm
sending love and light her way
the world tennis association has even
come out and talked about it the ceo and
chairman steve simon urging an
investigation into peng's whereabouts he
isn't even told the new york times chris
that maybe the wta might reconsider its
operations in china if they don't get a
sufficient response
what do you make of that does does the
world tennis association have that kind
of leverage in china
well first of all there's a confluence
of events here that's quite remarkable
right you have enos kanter and the nba
once again entangled in a big
geopolitical issue with china
with his essentially remarks he's making
that are critical of the chinese
communist party then on top of it you
have the beijing olympics right around
the corner less than 100 days from now
in february and then this incredible
controversy which is actually creating a
lot of dialogue among uh experts way
more expert than me as to exactly what's
going on because you did mention that
her post was up for 30 minutes and the
question is whether this is one of those
kill the chicken to scare the monkey
moments which is using a chinese proverb
in the way that xi jinping might
actually be trying to eradicate a rival
or whether it is actually something much
more straightforward
so what do you make of the timing of her
accusation and her seeming disappearance
from public life i mean you mentioned
ennis cantor and the nba he of course is
the basketball player the nba player who
had tweeted out his support of tibet
free tibet and and basically slammed
chinese premier xi jinping earning the
wrath of chinese government officials
well first of all you just had the six
plenum which is a huge event for the
chinese communist party and the central
committee
you also have the ranking of of john
galli who
up until 2018 was a standing committee
member there's only seven of them out of
the 92 million communist party members
so this is a hugely high profile scandal
if it indeed is that so the timing of it
could be xi jinping really trying to
eradicate rivals or on the other hand
something that came out that seems very
nefarious by an ally of his and
something that he wants to cover up as
quickly as possible and that might be
why we've noticed this disappearance
happen and i have fear for what's going
on with paying uh as far as her health
and um welfare right now does the fact
that you have people like naomi osaka
and even novak djokovic talking about
this change her fate in any way or how
china will deal with her
well first of all as we've seen with the
two michaels in canada um the the the
two canadians that were held captive in
china for so long that if there is a
groundswell of support and momentum by
people who are outspoken about a
disappearance or a false imprisonment
that can lead to some sort of a solution
i think it's very interesting to see
tennis players who have a lot at stake
when it comes to sponsorships and
endorsements and even appearances in
china come out in in involved and being
very activist in this role we haven't
seen that a lot by athletes mainly
because the money is so big in that
market so that could build momentum not
only to change um hopefully peng's
welfare into something that has a happy
ending but on top of it change the
dynamic of us going into the beijing
olympics in february
yeah and i want to get to that shortly
but but first i know that you were busy
earlier today you were actually um
speaking on this topic on national
security and sports in china
lecturing to the national roar college
in washington dc about this this is
something that you do every semester for
a course on soft power and influence
there um what do we need to know about
china's specific approach to national
security and sports that will help us
understand how to frame this current
conversation
well it's fascinating i mean captain
cory ray runs that particular class down
there at the war college and it's
fascinating and in fact looks at on the
history of the pentagon and department
of defense's use of narrative around the
world to achieve certain goals through
soft power influence but now it's really
turned its attention towards china and
the way that china approaches
cross-border censorship and cross-border
propaganda methods in order to spread
the messages that they want the rest of
the world to hear and adhere to so we're
seeing that just in in terms of the
pernicious uh behavior and uh in regards
to censoring the way we can criticize
them but then on top of it the way they
are mandating certain actions by
corporations to designate um nine-dash
line borders or to actually dictate that
taiwan can't be seen as a separate
nation on maps for airlines or uh what
have you so it's a really interesting
dynamic that's going on now where china
is really using soft power influence to
create much animosity around the world
and really influence people
um into thinking the way they want them
to think and how do chinese celebrities
like tennis star penguin or actors or
musicians or anyone else fit into that
soft power
well remember i mean the followings of
somebody like peng i believe she had 20
million weibo followers is really
powerful so when she comes out and makes
a statement like that obviously inside
china's borders it makes a real real
momentum move where as we saw after 30
minutes that was taken down and some
severe steps were taken
on the backs of that but then on top of
it the influence of these celebrities
around the world and how quickly that
gets picked up on social media platforms
worldwide is really remarkable and it's
something that the chinese government
both wants to curb when it's in terms of
criticism towards actions and policies
that they have but it's also ones that
they use to amplify in terms of getting
offensive directives out in narrative
right right they'll use it as it suits
them best i want to go to what you were
talking about which is the beijing
olympics it's due to take place next
year early next year in beijing and we
had mentioned before that china is going
to field an ice hockey team or ice an
ice hockey team whatever the verb is in
this case but it may not be able to do
so because they don't have enough
homegrown talent so there is there are a
couple of chinese professional hockey
teams one of them is the quinlan red
star and most of the players are
canadian and there's now questions over
whether china will be able to put
together this team and compete in the
games which technically my understanding
is that in the past it should have been
able to because it is going to be the
host right
yeah well what's fascinating with this
particular olympics is the winter
olympics and china is not particularly
good at a lot of those sports so they're
not going to have the metal count to be
able to amplify their image around the
world really these olympics are about
showcasing china in its adulthood stage
as the new rival superpower and the new
regional power power so they're really
trying to use it to showcase
infrastructure the glory and majesty of
the nation and the competence of the
government there and in fact most of
that is going to be televised rather
than seen in person because remember
only really the athletes and the chinese
nationals can actually see and attend
these events so it's going to be very
interesting so something like the
chinese hockey team if they can't
compete at a level that's less than
embarrassing it becomes a real problem
for face with them so it's going to be
interesting to see how that plays out
and on top of that that's happening at
the same point where josh rogan of
washington post yesterday broke the
story of a possible diplomatic boycott
by the united states in regards to those
olympics yeah let's talk about that a
little bit more because that's not the
first time this has been brought up but
so far we've just kind of gotten
whisperings of that there is no
indication so far among olympians or
aspiring olympians that this is
necessarily going to happen
where is this coming from this idea that
there might be a diplomatic boycott is
this something for instance the white
house is seriously considering it or is
this just something that people are
saying should be considered
well i'm not an investigative reporter
like like josh rogan but he tends to
have pretty good sources but i will say
the momentum for this started the build
i think when senator mitt romney first
brought up the idea and it's an idea
that's been used in the past and it's
actually one that's sort of an
interesting
way to allow athletes to go perform and
to compete at the level that they have
been training at for so long and
sacrificing so much for yet not
validating the chinese government during
a time when there are so many issues
that we have with them not just our
country but most of the west and include
include into that a lot of their
regional players so to validate them by
allowing them the full scope of what
they want to showcase is not probably
the right thing to do so a diplomatic
boycott allows sort of uh have your cake
and eat it too issue got it got it what
might be the catalyst to actually go
through with that diplomatic boycott
what do you think it might be linked to
pink tray for instance if there is no
resolution there what would be the
catalyst
well it's interesting a lot of the a lot
of the um opponents to boycotting are
obviously the athletes who have
dedicated their life and so much to
competing in these olympics but if
athletes start to get behind her
disappearance and demand answers and
demand her set free or whatever her
situation is that could create a
groundswell among other athletes because
athletes tend to have a lot of brethren
solidarity among them because they go
through so many similar
capacities as they train so it'll be
interesting to see how athletes
support this and how they move forward
with the olympics but i would say at the
same time we definitely see a lot of
tense issues between the two countries
and the rest of the west diplomatically
so i wouldn't be surprised if we
actually take this diplomatic boycott to
heart got it got it and we'll be looking
to see if anything like that does happen
chris you've spent years um selling us
sports namely basketball and u.s movies
to a chinese market so you've seen the
compromises that businesses and leaders
are willing to make in order to preserve
access to the potential of the chinese
market what mistakes do you think
american sports leagues american
businesses american executives
consistently make when it comes to china
well there's the mistake if you're
looking on a capitalistic basis i mean
the mistakes aren't
aren't really there they're actually
doing a lot of the right things in order
to protect the fiduciary
responsibilities of growing the value of
these different entities and generating
new revenues from that huge market where
i think the problem is is the fact that
we have been um over kowtowing we have
actually been really selling the soul
and the values and the principles of
what makes america what we are today and
what was really the foundation of
capitalism to begin with in order to
gain access to that market so the
long-term health of america and the west
our western allies and sort of the
health of capitalism overall is being
compromised on on the backs of
short-term gains so i think we really
need to start thinking of uh more of a
patriotic uh version of a first agenda
item before we embark on capitalism in
order to protect what's important to
america but yet we don't want to
decouple from china there is a great
market there there's a lot of value in
having commercial and cultural exchange
with our rival superpower and quite
frankly it will keep us from staying
away from a war which none of us want
yeah who's the leader to to help us lead
that to lead the reassessment of this
dynamic that we have with china i mean
is it the federal government is it an
industry is it a particular executive
well i think it's going to take some big
big names to take on that muhammad ali
effect of both being world class and
whatever their sport or discipline is
and then taking on an activism role i
would argue in the nba it's a lebron
james i would say in hollywood you have
somebody like a john cena you could have
corporate um you know sort of titans
like a phil knight and elon musk get
involved but you have to have the
government back it too we have to say to
these corporations that if there is
retaliation you have the government
backing you to prevent that from
happening and also help rally
other partners to back these companies
when they take these stands because the
last thing you want is nike to take a
stand and then suddenly adidas slides
right into their market
right you need to have a united stand
okay it's interesting because you
mentioned lebron you mentioned elon musk
you mentioned john cena these are all
three
uh people who are very much have high
profiles who have basically kowtow to
china i mean they've if anything bent
over backwards to make clear that you
know they were not on the same page with
those who have criticized china so
and china knows this too beijing knows
this full full and well so are they
really going to turn around and say you
know what let's lead an effort to resist
a little bit and to to take stock of
what we need to prioritize here
well look i would never call out any of
these people and say you need to do this
because they have so much skin in the
game right but what's going to happen is
that skin in the game the risk reward
calculus is going to change because
there's more of an awareness of this cow
italian pandering we're doing to the
with the chinese government in order to
gain access to that market that
consumers are starting to have a problem
with journalists are having an issue
with it politicians are having an issue
with it so we're going to start to see
consumers rebel against some of these
entities as they continue that course at
the same time we're seeing imitators in
the china market particularly in
hollywood which has seen market share
drop precipitously over the last decade
that market share is getting taken away
by an imitator so the reward of doing
what we have been doing to get into
china is becoming minimalized and the
risk of losing consumers in the west
over this continuous
continuing this engagement the way it
has been might start to gain momentum
and that is what's going to be the
tipping point gotcha gotcha chris thank
you so much chris fenton of course
joining us here he is author of the
feeding dragon really appreciate your
thoughts
you